salut à tous aujourd'hui une nouvelle
pêche dans le canal du midi avec un
condensé de mes meilleurs 3es 7 suspens
lors de mes trois dernières sorties
je viens de faire deux calibres 12 pas
tirer ou encore saint pas sympa en même
temps à une saloperie ainsi qu'une pièce
qui peut être cassé un au revoir mais
nettoyage à une autre pièce 5 centimes
comme quoi et là il y avait déjà de la
ferraille que certains ont laissé donc
c'est pas bien les gars se ramasserait
[Musique]
il
ça j'aime bien trouver des balles c'est
à dire qu'il peut y avoir larmes
il ya un truc ça y'a un truc
un moteur comment j'ai pu rater un arbre
c'est fou c'est fou un moteur donc quoi
il reste toujours un quart au petit
couteau
[Musique]
au fond de moi ça une balle waouh ça l'a
légué ce cas pas du neuf ça hu a
présenté une petite super regardez-moi
ça tout cas il ya une sacrée ogivins ça
rigole pas là et la balle a l'air bien
ajimi étonnant l étonnante une pièce de
5 centimes pour un endroit déjà prête
moi je suis pas mal
ma manette fishing pêche aller m'en
voyez péché oui le magnet pêcher les
métaux le faire monnet non je pêche le
faire mais sans se faire soit le faire
je le vends et des fois je garde les
pièces et des trésors des fois il ya des
vélos ouais de tous c'est une chasse aux
trésors assez de la pêche à leyment a
surtout le canal parce que quand il ya
des rochers ou des rondins c'est plus
compliqué quoi le canal c'est simple il
a été creusé par l'homme il est droit
voilà je fais partout vers béziers
colombier
non non non je veux ça comme ça rien
même pas ça des polluants sachez pas ce
que c'est
ouais des fois des morceaux de voiture à
ya plein de choses graves allant des
balles est pas moins attiré bâtir et
ouais mais tu peux montre ses jos
oui mais je garde pour la décoration
ouais pour la décoration
oui c'est moi oui ma maison rue oui oui
ah oui j'aime bien oui beaucoup des
bateaux et des fois ils jettent dupont
oui mais surtout avant voilà avant il
jeté beaucoup avant maintenant elles ont
un peu plus compris l'écologie quand
même et il laisse au bord de la poubelle
mais avant il ajouté tout j'ai trouvé
des casseroles away dessous
les barbecues à un corps shotgun
voilà c'est intéressant mais c'est un
choc
sur ses vieux alliés celle-là je t'ai
pas garder et je garde cela veut un
souvenir oui cadeau de bien conserver un
voile à 50 de voir ces lieux on se
retrouve de l'autre côté du pont donc ce
côté j'ai jamais fait toute cette partie
là est à faire j'ai déposé mes
trouvailles
et en russie m
je vais essayer de tirer un coup voilà
on va voir ce que tu trouves
ah non
156 la même aux capsules 1956 encore
plus vieille 56 celle là c'est super
vieux roi
c'est fou ça provenance pas réussi à
décrocher le truc qui bullent depuis
tout à l'heure et qui fait que de lâcher
quelque chose de gros très gros
et non d'accord
oui c'est vrai alpha mos au jeu pourtant
une lourde et souvent même pas je ne
sorte sur ça je pense que c'est
c'est que
à quelque chose
une chaîne
ah les cartouches et balmont au maïs à
la démo ça allait bel seule la superbe
ont vaqué de la ferraille au bord super
super on retourne à la chasse aux balles
quand nous y
c'est un peu
et alors peut-il heures
ça ce n'est pas une pelle
oh c'est quoi ce truc
waouh
il vient secoue toi
il est trop rouillé pour je loue voit la
super belles trouvailles
hop là en garde à alors en l'hameçon et
défense et mes fans donc là j'ai chargé
de côté pour avoir un autre angle j'ai
déjà chopé ça et encore une balle
calibre 12 plein paris seuil en rouge
l'échoppé vers là c'est sûr qu'il doit
rester les choses au moulinet enfin
c'est mon premier à dommages à quoi que
je sais pas je saurais pas dire si les
rentiers et on voit comment ça marche
voici les marches pour le faire sécher
nickel
on premier moulinet au jeu su faire il
allait en plutôt bon état a apporté
comme quoi ce spot restaurant sable le
couteau au moulinet la balle et les
douleurs c'est un plastique position on
peut voir que j 7 balles places offertes
qui a dessus je pense que c'était sous
l'eau avant même toute la partie qui qui
qui tient les balles entre elle et elle
a dû un peu fusionner avec la balle donc
c'est pour ça que je vais me rattraper
parce qu'autrement c'est une balle en or
les temps n'ont qu'à pas du tout faire à
l'intérieur du coup c'est une belle
trouvaille et c'est la preuve que des
les baladins avoir des tonnes
c'est juste qu'on peut pas les choquer
un peu ch éléments c'est quoi ça à une
vel enfin pas mal a jamais fait des
comme ça
sympa sympa mais là qu'est ce qu'on a
souffre indre
un bracelet de canettes
oh
y en a regardez-moi ça encore une encore
une fatigue babana maintien assez cassé
c'est cassé la baule à bâle pour vous
dire qu'ils sont vraiment dans un sale
état et fanja prend ses balles de la
guerre je la prends les classer
sachez pas ce que c'est
faut il ya encore des trucs
une voiture les petites plaies
quelque chose encore impressionnant
une scie
qu'est ce que c'est ça vous êtes une
sorte de moteur au poids
coker
ans de fac
what the fuck c'est quoi
fois la démence les giants
yahoo a juste là au bon à ok merci
à leur petit heures de pêche nickel ça
c'est cool aussi une pièce nice coule de
5e c bénef pour le brent est encore une
fois donc voici le résultat de la pêche
quelques centimes qui ont étaient
récupérables un couteau du rôle plutôt
pas mal en plus il fait tire bouchon le
plus important et le cran d'arrêt
fonctionne toujours avec le petit bouton
donc c'est sympa ensuite un moulinet qui
est aussi plutôt un bon état ça je veux
garder si un jour je me mets à la pêche
traditionnelle
après on a des balles donc cela l'a
perdue l'ogive mais toujours la poutre
l'intérieur donc je pense que je vais
l'enlever pour la neutraliser donc
derrière il ya écrit on va pas bien il
ya un petit roi en eau et 43 donc je
suis parce que c'est j'ai pas trop
cherché en détail et la plus belle
bastos c'est la plus belle que j'ai
jamais faite celle-là donc celle là on a
écrit 37 et 670 est ce un bon ça c'est
balle de gros calibre un bon s'appelle
chasse le worm de guerre d'abord
voilà donc c'était une très belle pêche
sous ce pont et je pense qu'il nous
réserve encore des surprises donc si ça
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à lâcher le
pouce bleus à vous abonner et on se dit
à bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo non x